[音楽]
お前たち
お金は
欲しくないかこんにちははじめしゃちょー
です
みんなこちらに1000万円
準備しました
1000円で
というわけでみんな大好きお金これ
1000円札なんですけども1000円札
を1000万円分準備しました1万枚です
はいはじめ
潜入印刷かよって思うと思いますけども
1000円札も1万枚あれば1000万円
ですこれ全部俺のなんですけどもう
みんなに
つかみ取りしてもらおうかなというわけで
視聴者参加型1000万円つかみ取り企画
はいこの動画を見てる皆さんおめでとう
ございますもう見てない人より得してます
何年か前にですねヒカルさんにもやって
もらったしいろんなYouTuberさん
にもやってもらったんですけども1億円の
つかみ取り大会みたいなやつをちょっと
実施しまして結構いろんな僕の知らない方
から連絡が来まして私も僕もやりたいです
お金が欲しいでないんですって
知らない人にあげる知らない人に1億円は
と言いたいんですけれども今回ちょっと
大盤振る舞いということで見てる皆さんに
もちょっとつかみ取りやってあげようかな
と思いましていつも応援してくださってる
いや応援してない方も参加でき
るっていうことを考えるとさすがに1億
あげれませんがまあ1000万円の中でし
たらどうぞということで今回皆さんに
つかみ取り企画をちょっと参加してもらい
たいなと思っておりますでもちろんただで
はあげませんそんなに世の中甘くないです
からお金のありがたみ知ってますお金好き
ですラブ
お金配ろうみたいなそんなしない話はあり
ません今回ですね僕が開発に手伝わせて
いただきましたスマホのアプリゲーム神
流し自慢のリリースがされたんですけども
皆さんはもう髪流し島遊びましたでしょう
かこの現金1000万円つかみ取り企画上
流し島の100万ダウンロード
達成記念企画としてやろうと思っており
ますはい
なんか行きそうなんだよなリリースされて
から結構ずっと1位なのでなんか調子は
すごいいいですけどすごい長い期間みんな
で考えていろんな人の協力があって
ようやく完成した髪流し島というゲーム
どうせだったらもっといろんな人に遊んで
もらうと思いまして100万ダウンロード
達成企画ということでちょっとやりたいと
思ってますので100万ダウンロード行か
なかったらなしですお疲れ様でした以上
ですなりたくないので皆さんぜひ流して
しまうインストールしてちょっと遊んでみ
てください動画の概要欄にリンクあります
もうとりあえずダウンロードして
インストールして遊んでみてくださいで
ここからは応募資格とか色々話していき
たいと思いますまずはですね実施場所どこ
で1000万円つかみ取りできるかと言い
ますと東京かなわかんないなまだ決まって
ないんですけども関東関東圏内になると
思っておりますすいませんあくまで予定な
のでまだわからないんですけどもあと交通
費は実費なのでそこもちょっと間違いない
ようにお願いしますまあその分稼げばいい
んですけどもで実施時期細かくは決まって
ないんですけれども8月以降8月以降の
土曜日か日曜日を予定しておりますこれも
決まり次第早めにアナウンスすると思い
ますのでぜひお待ちください
応募方法なんですけれども
専用の
応募フォームから応募ができますそこに
使命とかちょっと必要な情報を書いて
いただいて今回応募の資格の中に紙流し島
のアプリをダウンロードしてい
るっていうのを条件にありますので
紙流しにはインストールして遊ぶと
チュートリアルが始まりましたで
チュートリアルクリアしてプロフィール
ページに行くと自分のIDが表示されます
島のユーザーIDとユーザー名をそちらの
フォームにぜひ書いてください
是非というかもう書いてくださいこれ応募
条件なのでやってなかったら落ちてしまい
ますのでぜひお忘れなくお願いします注意
なんですけども
応募した後にアカウントの削除はIDが
変わってしまうのでちょっとそれは行わ
ないでくださいそのまま削除せずあの
良かったら見逃ししますぜひ遊んでみて
くださいでもっと細かい応募の資格対象者
です2つありますアプリをインストールし
てチュートリアルも終わってIDを持っ
てる人これが1つ目もう1つがちょっとお
金が
絡むので本当はね18歳以上とか大人だけ
にしたかったんですけども
キッズの皆さん出番です今回ですね12歳
以上の方対象とさせていただきますが
未成年の方は親御さんの同伴が必須となり
ますのでぜひあのお父さんお母さんお金
掴めるよと連れてきてあげてください目の
色が変わると思います続いて当選人数この
1000万円のつかみ取りできる人数
[音楽]
10名とさせていただきますはい10名の
方が参加できますこの掴み取り
たったの10名だと終わらせませんなんと
1000万円の掴み取りとは別に100年
の方にお札じゃなくてチャレンジャリンの
方の100万円分の掴み取り
準備してます
100万円分ですよ僕はこの企画のために
1100万円を応援している人もいると
思います
応援してない人もいるかもしれませんが
知らない人に全く知らない人にプレゼント
これ100万円分ですね100円玉が
50万円分50円玉が50万円分で
100万円分ありますこれ100名様に
当たりますけどもちょっとどんなもん
かって気になると思うんすよ皆さんこれ気
にならないですけど何円取れるんだろうっ
て1回やってみますLINE取れるか
あちなみにあのそう簡単に1000万あげ
ませんから1000万円の掴み取りも
ちゃんとルールがあるのでちょっとこの後
話すけど100万円つかみ取りはもう
シンプルに片手で取った分全部あげます
いきます
[音楽]
結構取れたはい
だいぶよちょっと集計します
[音楽]
はい今やってみたところ
1万3350円でした
[音楽]
沖縄から来るとマイナス交通費で遠くから
来た人からするとマイナスになるかもしれ
ませんが1万円ぐらいは超えそう100円
なめっちゃ少なかった超場所悪かったな
100円でもこれだけであと全部50円玉
なんで結構場所が悪かった100円玉の
ところ引くだけでも
倍になってくんで適当なこと言えないん
ですけど1万円は絶対超える気がします
絶対とは言えない多分こういうチャンスも
ありますでもさあ1万もらえるって言っ
たらさ
嬉しくねだったら参加するけどな100
名様に当たる100万円つかみ取り企画
そしてさっき説明してなかったんです
けれども1000万円のつかみ取り企画
ルール説明しますヒカルさんが見てて思っ
たんですけども結構つかめるのよお金って
実は1億円の掴み取り5000万持ってか
れてますからねっていうのを踏まえてです
ねちょっとゲーム性を持たせたくてルール
プレイヤーにはですねサイコロを振って
もらいます
振ってもらって出た目に応じて
掴み方が決まります一応今1と6だけ決め
てるんですけれども6が出た場合もう問答
無用です思いっきり
片手ガシ
掴んで持って帰っちゃってください
ちょっと悩み取れるか試してみましょう
つかんだ分全部もらえますからね行きます
マジで本当にそう深めに入って
やばい」って本番でこれ起きたらやばいっ
て
落とさずにこのまま下ろせた分だけ自分の
お金になります
はいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばい
はい今こんだけつかめました一発で
[音楽]
最悪や出ていくとねこんな取れるのよ数え
てみます
[音楽]
あこれ笑えんわマジで
やばい20万いってるもん20万いってて
このまま利用よ
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
これやばいわちょっとごめんなさい見たく
ないのでやめます一応30万円分抜いたと
してもまたこれだけあるんすよちょっと
どれぐらい取れるか本番のお楽しみという
ことで取っときますけども30万ぐらいは
軽くありましたっていう話だけしちゃっ
たって言います
ロックだけ行かないでくれ
次はサイコロで1が出た場合これが一番
低くなると思いますすいませんあの
ちょっとまだ調整中なのでルール変わっ
たらごめん1出たら今考えてるのはなんか
マジックハンドとかかなって思ってます
こんだけの大きさしかないからそんな取れ
ないかなと思いつつもちょっと1回検証し
てみましょうこれね塊を狙ってるのが一番
大事なので多分行きますよここからこう
入って
あーこれやばいな結構いったなこれこん
だけ取りました
数えます
けどもあるな結構
なるほどねマジックハンドで
4万5000円取れました
ちょっとしたハイブラの小物がエロい見て
いきますマジックハンドそんな狙い場所
多分良くなかった気がするんですけど雑に
とって4万ぐらいだったのでちょっと本番
までにもうちょっとルールは見直そうと
思いますがそういう感じで1000万円の
つかみ取りはサイコロでどう掴めるかが決
まるっていうのだだけちょっと覚えておい
てくださいそういうルールでさせて
いただきますはいというわけで
1000万円の掴み取りと100万円の
掴み取り準備させていただきましたいや
もうねー
緊張する俺はけどそれでみんなが幸せに
なって作ったゲーム神流し自慢がみんなが
遊んでくれればハッピーです
詳しい内容は動画の概要欄にありますので
そちらから是非チェックしてみてください
なんせねそれほどにまでも俺は神流して
しまってるゲーム本当に面白いので
ちょっとみんなに遊んでもらいたいと思っ
てます
我がお金の力を使ってても盛り上げたい
ゲームなので皆さんぜひインストールして
遊んでみてくれるととても嬉しいですでは
皆様の掴み取りの応募お待ちしております
バイバイ俺のお金
[音楽]